Let's go to areaCode six, seven, eight.
Who's calling today from six, seven, eight?
Today, it is a J-P from Marietta, Georgia.
How are you, JP?
How are things in Georgia?
I'm worried about you guys.
That's actually what I was calling about,
I didn't have really a particular question
besides just for your comment on the state
of things.
Yeah, I'm in the suburbs outside of Atlanta.
And, you know, we have got tons of cases,
you know, every day in Georgia.
Yep.
And I work at a music shop and I'm back in
the store.
I mean, there's no any kind of mass M&A or
anything, even for the employees.
Not for the customers, for anything.
Yeah, it's it is just ridiculous.
I'm restring and people have guitars that
they're bringing in and there's no way really
to sterilize them because they're instruments
and you can't put disinfectant on them right
through the wood.
But and I had a funny thing.
I even restrung and guitar signed by Paul
Ryan the other day, Leitrim Traumatic came.
Imagine having a guitar and wanting Paul Ryan
to sign it.
You know that.
That's crazy.
It had a Romney Ryan sticker on it.
So I think it was part of a promotional giveaway
or raffle or something like that.
So it's I'm hearing that.
Yeah, you're you're feeling unsafe at work,
essentially, like you're totally unprotected.
People are coming in.
They're handing instruments back and back
and forth.
You're not wearing a mask.
They're not wearing masks.
Right.
I mean.
Well, I do wear a mask every day.
Oh, you do?
OK.
You know, I've got said I absolutely.
It's just not required.
Yeah.
So I have more conservative bosses and we're
even back to doing like our bread and butter
lessons, in-person lessons.
And we've been doing in private lessons in
the store for a while as well, myself included.
Wow.
And now was was the store at one point closed
when things were more shut down?
Yeah, we shut down from January to March or
thereabouts, and no one wanted Georgia.
You know, open the back up, we we came back
in full force.
They kept our lessons online for a few months.
Starting in June, you know, completely ignoring
all the numbers starting in June.
We just decided to let people start coming
back in for in-person lessons.
And do the owners or your boss or whoever.
I don't know what the structure is.
Do they even talk about preventing the spread
of the virus, or is it just like we're open
for business?
That's it.
We we have bought air purifiers and we've
got stations with with hand sanitizer.
And we've got cute little signs that they
say stay to get Harz apart.
But other than that, not really.
Wow.
Well, I mean, that's something I don't know.
And let me ask you this.
I have a couple of friends down in Georgia,
but I've not asked them about this in general.
Like when you go to the grocery store, when
people are out.
Is there increasingly the atmosphere that
things are just normal or are people overall
exhibiting any kind of caution?
It's really hard to say.
I mean, it's really split, just like, you
know, a good bit of you know, everybody is
with, you know, the people say, I'm not going
to be a sheep.
Yeah.
And, you know, masks are, you know, you know,
make you not a man.
Yeah.
You know, the other half of people seem like
they're taking it seriously, but.
And the school systems seem to be having a
problem with this as well.
Cobb County, where I am, said they were going
to come back in full force and then people
got mad and then they said they're going to
all virtual and now people are mad at that.
So I don't know what they're gonna end up
doing.
Well, listen, I don't envy you.
That sounds very, very tough.
And the Georgia numbers are not looking good.
All we can.
I mean, listen, at this point, I don't even
know what we're hoping for.
We're hoping for a treatment.
We're hoping for a vaccine.
We're hoping for some commonsense and the
removal of Trump.
But it's we're gonna have some tough months
ahead of us.
I think it's undeniable.
Indeed.
Yeah.
And.
Well, we'll have you absolutely I.
Thank you very much for your work and socially
your livestream and everything.
I'm glad you're having good success with those
there.
Good, informative way to keep up with the
lies that accompany Magnani and everybody.
You're spreading.
Thank you.
I really appreciate that.
Thanks for calling in.
Great to hear from you.
Let's go next to our caller from the four
zero two area code.
Caller from four zero two.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Hi, David, it's William from Omaha, Nebraska.
William from Omaha, the Oracle of Omaha is
how we're gonna put you into our into our
system.
OK.
Yeah, my question was actually about.
About an election that's going on in Nebraska
right now.
So there's the Democratic primary winner for
the U.S. Senate is Chris Jassan it and he's
recently recently screenshots have come out.
It's him making crude sexual jokes to his
campaign staff.
And the Nebraska Democrats have voted to replace
him with Alisha Shelton.
But since Jason EQT already won the primary,
he has to step down.
Right.
There have been petitions to call him to like
end his campaign.
And my question was, do you think there is
any chance that he actually steps down since
he already won the primary?
Because, like, I definitely don't want to
vote for his opponent, Ben Sasse.
I have no idea.
Now, is Ben Sasse cruising to reelection regardless?
It's it's kinda you know, I'm I'm not sure
he's the incumbent right now.
Yeah, he's he's.
Popular in my area, it's kind of hard to judge
from Omaha.
I mean, let me put it this way.
I've not read.
I've not read anything about that seat being
one of the ones Democrats could take.
Is that fair to say?
It's not like ripe for the picking for a Republican
to lose?
Well, yeah, Nebraska is also kind of a toss
up state.
Now, we used to lean Republican, but in the
more recent polls, we're getting more and
more blue.
So if there is in my opinion, if he doesn't
step down, I would think that it would be
for sure that Ben Sasse would get reelected.
Yeah.
I'm not able to find any polling.
I mean, listen, I don't think there's any
way to force this guy to step down.
I really don't know about the messages.
I don't know about the race.
I really don't know anything about it.
But I'm not aware of any way to force him
to step down.
And I guess the reason I was asking about
whether it would be closer or not is up if
if Ben Sasse is going to win either way, maybe
that figures into the calculation.
But I really just don't know enough about
it to say.
OK, well, thanks for your time, David.
I really appreciate.
Thank you.
I appreciate the phone call.